this video is sponsored by squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
we
finally got our high-end 2020 imac with
the 10 core cpu
and the 5700 xt graphics card late last
week
and now it's time to put it through its
paces comparing it to everything from
the imac pro
our 15 000 mac pro and of course the
high-end
16-inch macbook pro with the powerful
5600m graphics
which is what this video is all about
now we already compared the lower spec
2020 imac to the base 16-inch macbook
pro
and in that video we compared things
like the ports
the speakers the displays the
convenience of portability with the
macbook
the microphones and the webcams so
definitely check out that video if
you're interested in those differences
but in this video it's all about
performance
to help you decide which mac you should
buy here are the specs of both machines
and as you can see the macbook pro is
quite a bit more expensive
but it does come with the one terabyte
ssd which is a nice bonus
and on the other hand we loaded the imac
up with 64 gigs of ram
for only 250 from amazon since it's so
much cheaper than apple's 1 000
upgrade price and it literally only
takes a minute to do it yourself
so if you end up choosing the imac
absolutely upgrade the ram yourself
and you can find links to the best deals
on ram down in the description below
now before we get into the performance i
want to mention that the imac benefits
from a better cooling system
double the ram two more cpu cores and
double the graphics vram
which runs at the same gigabytes per
second bandwidth
as the super fast hp m2 in the 5600m
graphics on this 16 inch macbook pro
starting with geekbench 5 cpu test
the imac has about 15 percent more
single core performance but a very
impressive
32 percent higher multi-core score so it
definitely has a huge advantage there
but that's just raw performance in the
cinebench r20 stress
test which factors in the cooling
systems there was an
even bigger difference with the imac
being a huge
sixty percent more powerful showing the
advantage of the much larger cooling
system
so even though the imac isn't portable
like the macbook pro
that 60 difference in heavy workloads
could be worth it for a lot of people
now moving on to graphics benchmarks we
tested raw graphics performance using
geekbench 5's metal test
and the imax 5700 xt was about 34
percent more powerful
than the macbooks 5600m which is
actually still
impressive being faster than the 5500 xd
card
in the 2300 imac moving on to gaming
performance using unigine's heaven
benchmark on the extreme preset
the imac got around 20 more fps and it
performed very well
when we played a couple of games under
windows 10 using bootcamp
in our gaming review of the imac so
definitely check that video out if
you're interested
now since unigine uses opengl we also
ran some metal based benchmarks
using gfx bench metal 5.0 in the 1440p
aztec ruins test the imac was 42 percent
more powerful than the macbook pro
and in the manhattan test the imac
scored an even bigger
46 percent more than the 5600m in
the macbook so it looks like it's even
better for metal based benchmarks
but as we all know benchmarks don't tell
us the full story
not at all as you're about to see in the
real world tasks
but before we get into those let me give
a huge shout out to squarespace
for sponsoring this video if you've been
thinking about making your own website
squarespace is seriously the best way to
go i built an engaging website for my
wife's cleaning business
with literally no web making experience
you just choose a template
customize blocks of text and images and
easily move them around
it's incredibly simple affordable and
it's been running flawlessly for almost
two years
bringing in new clients thanks to its
built-in seo tools
so whether you're making a website for a
small business or for literally anything
else go to squarespace.com for a free
trial
and use our custom link below when
you're ready to launch to save 10
on your first purchase of a website or
domain getting back to those real world
tests
we're going to start off with photo
editing using lightroom classic we
exported 500 raw 42 megapixel photos on
both machines
and to our surprise the macbook pro kept
up very well
only taking a couple more minutes to
export all of those photos
so while the imac is faster for photo
exporting
it's not that big of a difference now
our macbook pro is loaded with 32
gigabytes of ram
and that's incredibly important for
photo editing as we discovered in our
how much ram do you need for max and
2020
video we used the 2020 imac and simply
going from 16 to 32 gigs of ram
saved us over 4 minutes in this test so
it seems like ram
is the most important factor for photo
editing now before we get into video
editing with final cut pro 10
where we saw the most surprising results
let's first show off the results from
the new
logic pro 10 benchmark for music
producers
the high end imac with the 10 core cpu
was able to handle
a pretty impressive 131 tracks being
played at the same time
compared to 97 tracks with the macbook
pro
that's 35 more performance for music
production
we also tested one of the older versions
of blender which uses the graphics to
render the bmw
and classroom tests and the imac
finished about 5 minutes quicker
which we think benefits from running at
higher clock speeds
now let's finally get into video editing
starting with the bruce
x 5k benchmark in final cut pro 10. here
it was surprising to see that there was
literally no difference at all
the macbook pro was able to finish the
test in the exact same 9 seconds
possibly due to the hbm2 memory and then
moving on to our one minute 4k
hevc stabilization test the imac
finished around two and a half seconds
faster which doesn't sound like much but
it's still a
25 improvement which could add up over
time now moving on to our export tests
we exported a 5 minute 4k h.264 clip
with added effects
which is the most common format that
youtubers use
and to our surprise the 16-inch macbook
pro actually finished a couple of
seconds faster
the main reason for that is because
these machines aren't limited by the cpu
or the graphics
in this specific test they're actually
both using the same
integrated uhd graphics 630 chip with
quick sync
technology to encode so that small
difference might be due to the 5700 xt
not being quite as optimized now
exporting a 5 minute hevc clip
the imac is surprisingly slower once
again by 13 seconds this time
which is a bit disappointing considering
the huge difference in raw performance
we saw earlier
but this test is also not dependent on
raw performance
atvc footage is actually taken care of
by
apple's t2 chip and the hardware
accelerators in the navi based graphics
the important thing to know is that last
year's imac that lacked both of those
things
took much longer in this test over 6
minutes
compared to the new 2 minute and 42
second time so it's definitely
a huge improvement but as for why the
imac is slower than the macbook
we think it's because the imac is
incorrectly using quick sync to export
instead of using the t2 chip like the
macbook pro is using
so it seems like final cut is still
telling the imac
to use quick sync for this codec since
last year's imac
didn't have those new hardware
accelerators but we are expecting final
cut pro to be updated very soon
to start using the navi based
accelerators that can encode
8-bit hvc at up to 90 frames per second
instead of 60 using the t2 chip so the
imac should either match the macbook
pro or outperform it when that update
gets released
now finally moving on to some heavier
raw codecs
this is where the imac starts to shine
in the 5 minute c200 raw export test
the imac finished over a minute faster
because this test is very graphics
dependent
which gives the imac an advantage but
then moving on to exporting a 5 minute
4.5 k
red raw clip the imac blows the macbook
pro out of the water
because this codec is dependent on both
the cpu
and graphics power and then exporting a
one minute 8k
redraw clip we see an even bigger
difference
with the imac finishing almost three
times as fast as a macbook pro
which could be due to the fact that this
codec is tough on vram
and the imac has 16 gigs of memory
compared to 8 gigs on the macbook pro
we also decided to run a couple of video
editing tests in davinci resolve
16 studio starting with a blackmagic raw
6k to uhd export test here the imac pro
blew the macbook pro out of the water
once again
finishing over a minute quicker which is
huge for that kodak
and the main reason why is because this
footage is
very heavily dependent on graphics and
vram
with the macbook pro we noticed that
while running this test
the eight gigs of vram was completely
maxed out
and that was actually the major
bottleneck so the 16 gigs of vram on the
imax
5700 xt graphics allowed it to run this
test
much quicker and now moving on to our
final test
temporal and spatial noise reduction
using blackmagic raw footage
here we basically see a 30 improvement
for the imac
which basically matches up to the 34
improvement in raw graphics power
that we saw using geekbench 5's metal
test so now with all of that out of the
way
let's finish up with some conclusions we
can pull from all of these tests
before we get into recommending which
mac you should buy we were surprised by
how well the macbook pro kept up with
the imac
and even beat it in some video editing
tests
this is mainly because of that high-end
super fast 5600m graphics
and if apple didn't just release it and
we were instead
testing with the previous best 5500m
graphics
then the imac would have smoked it the
5600m
uses basically the same 40 core graphics
chip
as the 5700 xt but it's simply running
on less watts
compared to the imac which isn't battery
powered but
in general there are mainly two things
that caused the imac
to perform much better in some of these
tests one of them was the fact that the
5700 xt graphics card
has 16 gigabytes of vram which we
noticed was the bottleneck on the
macbook pro
with only having eight gigs for the
heavier tasks
especially for certain raw codecs but
keep in mind that only the 5700 xt
option on the 2020 imac has 16 gigs of
vram
all of the other options have eight gigs
or less
which will be slower than the macbook
pro in most tests
now the second thing was the drastic
difference in processing power
with that 10 core cpu coupled with the
much better cooling system
that allows it to keep the clock speeds
higher than on the macbook pro
both of these things made a huge
difference for heavy hitting codecs
like raw footage so the imac is
obviously the better choice for things
like that
if you're looking purely at performance
differences
especially since the imac is actually
quite a bit cheaper than the 5600m
16 inch macbook pro however the macbook
also packs the same t2 chip and
navi based hardware accelerators as the
imac
which allow it to perform the same or
even slightly better than the imac for
lower end work
like regular 4k h.264 editing or
dealing with 4k hvc footage which is
becoming
increasingly more common so if you're
just doing basic 4k
editing and you're not dealing with
heavy raw codecs
the macbook pro is actually a great
choice and the same thing goes for photo
editors
where the performance difference was
surprisingly small now let's finish up
with which models you guys should buy
if you think you'd enjoy the portability
of the macbook pro
then just buy the macbook pro because it
still performs quite well compared to
this
high-end imac especially for common
video editing tasks and things like
photo editing but if you want the most
performance you can get for the least
amount of cash
the imac is actually a much better
choice since you can upgrade the ram
yourself and save around 550 dollars
compared to this high-end macbook pro
and you also get a larger display and
then you end up getting much better
performance for higher end codecs like
raw footage
you'll get better performance for logic
pro music production
you'll get 16 gigs of vram you'll get
quite a bit better gaming performance
and i'm fairly certain that performance
should improve for common tasks
when the imac finally starts getting
optimized now the biggest question is
whether you should actually upgrade to
the 10 core cpu on the imac
or just stick to the eight core now
we've been comparing the two and getting
very interesting results
so if you want to see that comparison
video definitely click the circle above
to subscribe
and if this video helped you guys out
definitely check out our apple product
merch
down below including our new apple
product mask
which comes with black icons and white
icons in a variety of different colors
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video